so I'm going to ask you to say and
you're gonna have to argue the opposite
great
in 60 seconds that Donald Trump does not
deserve a second term are you kidding me
so you've got to say why he does not
deserve a certain term in 24 and you're
going to say why he does so
I didn't even ask you know what's your
name
damage so Danish is going to go with why
Donald Trump does not deserve a second
term in 2024 off you get
term as president of the sa primarily
because he failed the first time the
definition of stupidity is to do
something that you know has failed and
then to do it again he is divisive he is
corrupt
um he is just not very good at his job
the national debt of the US Rose I can't
quote how much but more than it ever has
uh he is not a very good Diplomat the
amount of
um the amount of Statesmen and world
leaders he has pissed off and generated
negative relations for the U.S just
grows and grows
um people
say about Joe Biden that he's boring is
uninspiring that he is not uh you know
not a statesmanlike figure Donald Trump
is an order of magnitude worse than that
Donald Trump is morally an awful person
that might not matter in a world of
Boris Johnson where she's soon act
Victor Auburn but it it should matter
you want your you want your leaders to
be
good people to inspire the the populace
um you if you're a supporter of them you
want to be able to ride into battle for
them I I wouldn't want to go into battle
for Boris Johnson for instance I
very good
well done Dinesh hold on to the
microphone
with Danesh has laid down the challenge
so you mediter now have to give me can I
just say before you start your clock
there are people filming in here I just
want to make it clear things are clipped
out of context I do not believe what I
am about to say I do not believe what
I'm about to say this is a hypothetical
for the sake of argument which is very
much for the record we'll have a
watermark on the YouTube so you've
noticed the technique of getting more
time you notice that I hope also
preemption preemption so 60 seconds on
why Donald Trump deserves a second term
in 2024. okay I could give you many
reasons I'm going to give you three as I
say in the book you should always have
three reasons my three reasons is number
one what were you talking about with the
record Donald Trump's record on the
economy whether we like it or not has
leftists and liberals was a great record
until covert came along unemployment was
very low interest rates were lower than
they are now so whether we like it or
not is economic was fantastic his covid
record do you want me to give you a
great statistic with a horrible
statistic more people have died from
covert on Joe Biden died on Donald
Trump's watch did you know that but you
didn't know that number two number two
let me just say this Donald Trump is
younger than Joe Biden I like Joe Biden
but I don't want my president to die in
office there's a very good chance God
forbid Joe Biden could dine off and
Donald Trump is a healthy man he eats
cheeseburgers he drinks Coke but you
can't deny he has some serious energy
with all those long speeches so he's
healthier than Joe Biden and number
three give the man a chance he's only
running because Barack Obama made fun of
him in 2011. so let him have a chance to
be president on his own self
I don't believe what I just said do not
clip this out of context
very nice I'm gonna that was brilliantly
done I think Dinesh if you if you don't
have a question as well do you you were
here for the debating which is great so
I think you can hand the microphone on
to your next Challenger big hamper
Dinesh
[Music]
tell us your name hi I'm Zara firstly um
if I could lose any argument B22
okay sweet but I'm not gonna hold back
so the challenge for you is I want you
to say why the Middle East needs less
Western intervention not more Johnny
you're killing me here you're killing me
the Middle East is a region with vast
cultural and intellectual history it has
advanced the Western world like crazily
in comparison to what we have achieved
the first University was from a Muslim
woman
um algebra was created by a Muslim in
the Middle East and there is a rich
history which is ignored by the Western
media and often the West would like to
intrude their opinion into how the
Middle East should live their life but
really they should concentrate on
themselves because there are a lot of
issues in the western media and the
Western world right now and intervention
with the Middle East has
historically not gone well for example
Iraq for example
um Obama bombing Somalia for example
Iran and the intervention with
Afghanistan also so there is a history
of the intervention not going well and
there's not been a time where the the
Western world has intervened with the
Middle East and appropriately had a good
outcome
very good thank you
so
so Zara says Western intervention in the
Middle East has not been a good thing
oddly media San disagrees
you could delete that email in your
inbox in in 60 seconds to be clear
before you start the clock I do not
believe what I'm about to say yeah 60
seconds on why the Middle East needs
more Western intervention not less it's
a no-brainer and once again I have three
reasons you should always have three
reasons you're going to remember them
they're good number one Zara mentions
Iraq funny Zara that you didn't mention
Syria where tens of thousands hundreds
of thousands of people died they wanted
Western intervention we didn't do
Western invention because idiots like me
were saying don't intervene in Syria and
I may have to concede now that I was
wrong about that and actually we should
have intervened in Syria to save lives
number two how do you define
intervention Johnny you had a smile on
your face you acted like intervention
means military intervention well I
refute your framing of the argument I
reframe it and say Western intervention
means support for the Palestinians at
the UN Western countries should back the
Palestinians at the United Nations
security Council that would be a good
intervention
and number three
I was just in the Middle East in
December and all I did was eat at Five
Guys and McDonald's
love Western intervention in the form of
Halal Western Restaurants don't deny it
we love it we love it
very good indeed Zara well done Zara
[Music]
[Applause]
our third Brave contestant what is your
name I'm Sam you're Sam Sam I'm going to
ask you to give us 60 Seconds
on why Gary I knew it I knew it
why Gary lineker was in the right and
should not have to apologize
thank you very much for the motion so
we're a country of free speech stuck
right ladies and gents free speech Yes
speech thank you free speech our
presenters should be able to say what we
want to be able to say whether it's
right or wrong an opinion is an opinion
would you agree yes thank you very much
would you agree ladies and gentlemen
thank you very much so we are a free
country we have the right to do whatever
we wish to do whether it's right or
wrong we can agree on certain things we
can disagree on certain things it's
different it doesn't matter whether he's
a sports presenter whether he's a top
BBC journalist it shouldn't matter he
can have the right to say whatever he
wants to say about
feet twitching so much you should have
the right to say whatever he wants to
say
whether people disagree with him or
agree with him we're a land of the free
and not American we are British and we
are proud to be British and we should
stand with our media journalists with
their Sports journalists they should
have the right to say whatever they wish
to say regardless of the issue thank you
thank you Sam love it
[Music]
thank you very much I do not believe
what I'm about to say about my beloved
Gary lineker but nevertheless your
position is that Gary lineker should
apologize and he was in the wrong all
right let's go Sam you want to do q a do
you so let's play some q a do you
believe let's do three reasons three
questions do you believe that we are a
country of rules and laws yes or no okay
then so there are rules at the BBC
social media guidelines you may not like
them Gary line could breach those social
media guidance they're very clear in
partial study guide us I agree with
linnica what linica said was right but
he broke the rules that's number one
number two do you Sam do you think we
should offend Jewish communities
gratuitously are you pro-offending Jews
no well Jewish communities were offended
by what Gary lineker said about the
1930s I don't think we should
unnecessarily offend Jewish communities
we should phrase our language and our
analogies in a way that doesn't offend
you third of all do you like hypocrisy
Sam are you pro-hypocrisy
so I want to bring up hypocrisy here
because you know the Tim Davey the BBC
director General was asked if he had
praised the government would you have
blocked him and Tim Davis said I'm not
going to answer that which basically
means he wouldn't have let it go I'm
saying let's ban hypocrisy across the
board we would have been annoyed Had
Gary lineker praised Sue Ella bravaman
so I want to say in the interests of
consistency and decency
if we're annoyed if he Praises we should
be annoyed if he criticizes her let's
not be Hypocrites people
[Music]
and I don't believe what I just said
[Applause]
terrific
well
I think our champion debater has made
his point but only through the Fantastic
contribution from our three Debaters
Zara Danesh and Sam big hand for them
there you go thank you
very very good sports indeed they had no
idea that was coming nor did I Jonathan
nor did I and uh the you did say that
you feared when I
foreign